the hell is with these cops
you know we're we're like me we're not
ikea but we're not quite designed within
reach yet yeah we're cb2 but like
usually usually you have one that says
the pete holmes show these look like
they got them in a yard sale
they're mismatched
this set is crazy there's a block of
wood
dude there's not even forget a desk man
they basically put a third stool here
and we're like yeah just use the one
with a hard top to rest your on
it does look like someone was stacking
these in a brooklyn like stock this is a
prop from a law order
like someone was like oh yeah i've seen
her
yeah this they didn't want to give us
mugs with my name on it this is from the
tbs no competence edition
yeah you're they're waiting for the next
white guy to give a talk show too
why is that sad we could all agree that
there's like only white guys that host
talk shows arsenio
talk shows on real channels
what channel is arsenio's on
i would say b-e-t adam don't say b-a-a-t
adam don't say b-e-t keep looking at
pete don't say b-th
adam don't say p-e-t
adam stop it don't say p-e-t adam adam
stop it adam don't say the n-word
at the end you got to flash an urge to
say the n-word well just because i was
like it was like a michael richard's
hole there for a second yeah no i i
loved it it was a real well that's why i
wanted to have you on the first week is
because i said to you do you remember
yes i said letterman's first guest was
bill murray yeah and he came on and
really kind of you know yeah and i was
so honored i was so honored that he
thought of me that way and then i saw um
when i was in the hospital i saw a
couple of shows and i was like oh he
doesn't need me to ruin it
see what's happening right now is
i know we're chums but they're like i
don't know yeah but that makes it
that'll make it even better
for the tv audience well for me when i
leave
it was a very good moment you went you
went to zero very quickly yeah that's my
acting skill is it yeah i can go dead
eyes in two seconds can you can you go
from big to dead eyes for me yeah huge
so like
what
that's scary
can we agree that actors are kind of
sociopathic oh i would 100 agree right
yes
to be a really good actor i think you
have to be somewhat sociopathic and
somewhat dumb
you have to be an empty vessel that can
have words poured through you totally
like when i've done when i've been
acting like there
there's a uh
there was someone on on a show that i
was doing that was on some place and and
uh he was having a hard time the
director was giving him notes and he was
having a hard time
deciphering how to read the lines and
how to blog and he kept doing the thing
where he's like i don't understand why
my character would do this like i i
don't think my character would do that
sure and he like and he turned to me and
he was like what do you think and i was
like what do i think i think acti acti
acti smoky smoky smoky sleepy sleepy
sleepy checky checky checky
you